e
là il est 7 heures et nous partons à
l'aéroport d'orly pour aller récupérer
quatre chiens en provenance de l'île de
la réunion
[Musique]
on a la maman qui nous qui a ré la
petite femelle et puis nous bad optimale
et puis on allait au néo c'est un petit
griffon qui a failli mal terminée la
base sur l'île de la réunion puisque
c'est un chien très sociable qui a
atterri dans une école maternelle et
bien sûr là bas les chiens sont pas les
bienvenues encore moins dans une école
est forcément la fourrière a tout de
suite été appelés donc le chien a été
conduit à la fourrière et heureusement
on s'est battu pour qu'une de nos
bénévoles puissent me sortir de la
fourrière sinon c'était l'euthanasie au
bout de cinq jours on travaille beaucoup
avec les animaux des îles les chiens en
l'occurrence pour la réunion et chiens
et chats pour la guadeloupe
[Musique]
c'est pas évident surtout dahan période
qu'ovide de trouver des voyageurs qui
nous rapatrie afin qu'ils nous aident à
rapatrier des animaux sur la métropole
le voyageur n'a rien à faire mis à part
accepté d'avoir un chien sur sur son
billet et
et récupérer le chien la sortie de
l'avion sur le tapis des bagages
[Musique]
bonjour
famille tous
les jours
j'avais fait bon voyage
ça s'est bien passé à l'arrivée à donner
aux fous ça c'est mon petit coquin
celui-ci et des doigts que fait-on
timide
tout fait un timide mais je te connais
je t'ai vu déjà en photo
en tout cas merci
merci à monsieur merci au revoir
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là on a la maman des deux chiots
qui s'appelle king qu'on a les eaux le
petit léo qui ont été trouvés dans la
fameuse cour d'école qui revient de loin
mais ça c'est les deux petits le king
donc on accueille arrêt la petite noire
et blanche et nouba le petit l'autre
petit qui est caché là d'ailleurs voilà
donc là maintenant il ya une heure de
route pour aller à la villa derka donc
dans ma maison je les accueille
[Musique]
coucou les petits bébés
coco tu viens tu viens
ils ont perdu leurs petits manteaux
année
ouais
[Musique]
là je me sortir les chiens david ader
cas c'est à dire les miens j'ai deux
gros molosse qui accueille tous les
chiens qui arrive
voilà vous venez
depuis 2019 on a une super marraine on à
claude chirac qui a accepté d'être la
marraine de l'association
et puis oui on a de plus en plus on est
on nous approche enfin les écoles nous
approchent et cetera pour des projets
on a 380 chars qui ont été adoptées et
400 on doit être à 410 chiens-là
d'adopter alors là j'ai développement
d'outils nouba qui arrivent il faut au
portail
vous allez on y va on va voir tes
parents
[Musique]
où
voilà je vous ai amené votre petit
bonhomme
bah oui c'est un changement de
température incertaine et puis je suis
un petit peu recchi et que j'ai pu ma
petite soeur
thébaux nous met dans les bras il claque
des dents
simplisme ou pis il va s'appeler snow
pia signifie qu'elle a deux mois et demi
on va aller faire les papiers c'est
parti
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
on a tout préparé on lui a préparé son
panier s'est joué ces petites gamelles
et puis bon on va le présenter à nos
petits enfants à nos enfants et puis
voilà on va aller promener on va s'en
occuper on va de choyer
[Rires]
mon
[Musique]